what else Madison they claim it's a
quick and painless death performing is
banned in the UK but flourishing abroad
this is the glossy promotional video for
Danish fur farms demand is high and the
skins end up in fashion houses across
the world including Rebecca Bradley's
London workshop we have chinchilla and
sable and these are going to be two
collars some cuffs six chinchilla one
more and how much with a cave like this
tend to retail for 50,000 domestic fur
farms have been illegal here for 15
years
closed on moral grounds but we still
import foreign farmed fur fox raccoon
mink and seal you wouldn't differentiate
farming for fashion fantasy no I believe
that animal doesn't know why it's being
formed and therefore the use afterwards
is irrelevant
all the standards the same no and I
think that's why it's important to know
where you buy your products from the
same as meat the same as silk the same
as beauty products first being
controversial for years but now it's
political a public petition has
triggered a debate in Parliament and
Labour's backing an end to the trade I
was so proud when the Labour government
back in 2000 actually brought in a ban
on on fur farming in this country now we
want to take the next step and ban
interpretation of fur
altogether and the Conservatives instead
of being morally indefensible and
refusing to do so need to step at the
plate and follow Labour Party policy and
bound for very important millions of
animals and their lives in cages across
Europe before being electrocuted or
gassed for their fur animal rights
campaigners are hateful the government
like many labels will turn that back on
the industry Michael cause Gucci Versace
ball dropped fur they know it's the
right thing to do it's a sensible
business decision there are plenty of
synthetic alternatives to work with we
know that there's enormous public
support for a ban
and now we are looking to the government
to put this ban into policy but the
British fur trade say this is an issue
for consumers not politicians people
stigmatize fur but except leather or
they stigmatize lever and accept meat of
a stigmatized meat and they wear silk
what's important is the only welfare is
paramount then I believe it's up to the
individual to choose we may have banned
it on our own Shores
but foreign fur is still very much in
British fashion Sarah had Bagheri Sky
News